in this video i'm gonna explain the
warhammer titan which is the newest
titan shifter to be referenced
in the attack on titan anime it was
first mentioned during the second
episode of the final season
and is known to be possessed by a member
of the tiber family
since the great titan war over a hundred
years ago the warhammer
has never been used in battle and this
is partly the reason why the tiber
family is so respected worldwide
today we'll examine the warhammer
titan's strengths its weaknesses
and its various designs throughout
history big spoiler warning for those of
you who'd rather wait for the anime to
reveal this information
but for the rest of you let's get into
it and don't forget to sub for more
videos like this
okay so starting with the warhammer
titans strengths it's able to use a
special type of hardening that lets you
create a variety of weapons the weapons
it makes will usually manifest inside
its hands
as we saw in the trailer for season 4
how it conjured up a hammer
literally out of thin air this type of
hardening is special because
it actually has a degree of flexibility
as shown when it created a crossbow
which
of course requires an elastic string to
make it functional
normal titan hardening just does not
work that way so the warhammer has the
advantage
of being able to make flexible long
range weapons like whips or crossbows
this titan can also cause structures to
shoot out of the ground
such as this giant pillar that it made
or the spikes which look very similar to
stepping on a lego brick
in the entirety of the series so far as
of making this video the warhammer has
used its power to create a trident
a whip a crossbow a hammer a sword not
to mention conjuring spikes out of its
own body
out of the ground and obviously that
giant spiky pillow that i just mentioned
moving on to the warhammer's other
ability it's been long established that
the user of a titan shifter
can be found in the back of the titan's
neck but this is not always the case
when it comes to the warhammer
the user of this titan can choose to
encase themselves in a crystal
just like the one that annie is in and
then remotely control the warhammer
titan whilst inside it
there's a cable that connects the body
of the warhammer titan to the person in
the crystal
but the downside is that if this cable
is cut then the warhammer immediately
loses connection and becomes lifeless
the user can still make a new cable from
within the crystal and this will create
a new warhammer titan
however whilst the cable is vulnerable
the crystal itself is virtually
impossible to break into
which protects the user from something
like this happening to them
this titan's main weakness is that if it
creates too many structures in a short
space of time
then it will use up all its stamina and
be unable to make anything else
general mcgath outright said that the
power of the warhammer is quickly
exhausted
and we saw this play out during its
first appearance in the series
during its first fight the warhammer
made a ton of weapons
only for it to run out of energy after
about i'd probably say like 10 minutes
it's other weakness if you can call it
that is that its special hardening is
not indestructible
so it can be broken by other titan
shifters you know with repeated punches
or by biting with that said the
warhammer's design has several unique
features that separate it from other
titans
and thanks to some throwbacks in the
manga we've gotten glimpses of the
different warhammer titans throughout
history
one thing they all have in common is
that their flesh is covered in a thin
layer
of special hardening with enough space
for their eyes and mouth to be seen
the markings that we saw on the
warhammer titan's nape are reminiscent
of the markings that appear on the
on the user of a regular titan shifter
the user of the warhammer titan never
gets any markings on their actual face
because they're
obviously they're inside this crystal so
judging by the similarity of these two
lines
i'd imagine that it was just a visual
choice to put it on the titan itself
one of the former titans had these lines
on its face and another one had it along
its weird cape this warhammer
specifically had the freakiest design
but when you consider what i mentioned
earlier about how it has elastic
hardening that is flexible
you can understand why a titan like this
existed in the past
additionally another thing that makes
this titan stand out is the fact that
its body does not have to materialize
from the neck
like other titans do instead the
warhammer's body materializes from
whichever body part the cable is
connected to
in this clip we see how the warhammer is
taking shape from the bottom
upwards and that's because the cable was
attached to its foot in this moment
in a different situation the warhammer
can materialize from its head or any
other body part as long as that's where
the cable is attached
anyway guys that was the warhammer titan
explained and obviously if you've
watched this far i'm assuming you don't
care too much about spoilers
so if you want to know who has this
titan in the anime then it is the
sister of willie tiber so she was very
you know
when she first appeared in the anime she
was very much in the background she was
very easy to miss
i'm pretty sure she even had her eyes
closed um but yeah she was the person
who was selected
and when you think about it it makes
sense because willie tiber is meant to
be the head of the family right
and so if he has the warhammer then he's
gonna die within 13 years it's not great
so you'd rather have a head of the
family
that can stay in that position for a
really long time hence why it didn't
really make sense for him to have this
titan
be sure to drop a like if you like this
video and have a happy new year because
i will be posting this on the final day
of 2020 until 2021 peace out